[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record where we talk about
whatever we
want we were talking about butterflies
having sex
yup the lady butterfly layers on her
back yeah
so she's just like and she just receives
it from me and you said your mom's
and my mom told me that i thought your
mom was so unhorny but she is unhorny
that's why it makes sense that she's
talking about the baby
her mom's an actual liar because she's
horny as
[ __ ] oh really she's just like time you
know she's horny as [ __ ] just through
our coffee that's like my mom
she's our mom's like that nikki's mom i
can tell by looking in her eyes
sometimes
she gives you horny guys horny bro no my
mom's not horny she is
so this is what we so uh before we're
talking about but we're talking about
like spicing up the bedroom or something
like this like the [ __ ]
you were there we wouldn't be spicing up
the talk about this with the mom with
the mom nice like just doing different
things i don't know like doggy style or
whatever techniques
where the [ __ ] was i probably like
taking care of attack i don't know
and then so me we were talking about
like just different techniques or
different things
and then uh and i think it made it just
a random joke i'm like oh you probably
have handcuffs in your drawer or
something like that and she goes
what was not there and she was like when
you get to that age you have a lot of
things in your drawer
oh [ __ ] that's [ __ ] crazy and i was
like
i was like is there anything you haven't
tried because
when you get to that everything and i
was like
i love her this is like when i used to
take the subway in downtown l.a
and some sun mornings i would just be
sitting there and you're trying to be
polite to the person next to you
and you're like how's it going and
they're like wow i'll tell you
everything no yeah
that's a weird thing americans do i've
heard like europeans be like why do
americans ask you how you are but they
don't really want to hear an answer
and i'm like i don't know it's a weird
cultural thing but that whole thing
though that conversation you're having
with your mother-in-law it reminds me of
this story we're going to be talking
about later on today where i'm like
oh this is getting interesting obviously
that's not
the case here but it just sounds really
like
what's going on i just like whenever you
try to weird someone and they outweird
you
oh that's my favorite thing i was trying
to [ __ ] around with her and i think i
was gonna own her ass and then she
[ __ ] owns me and then she just says
that
she's and walks away to the fridge and
i'm just there with like my food like
what the [ __ ] yep that's what you get
[ __ ] gio was there
but doesn't remember i wasn't there i
don't remember any of this [ __ ] because
that would terrify me
take care of tyka do you have a handle
of rum in your hand
and you're passed down on a beanbag
chair to forget just to [ __ ] culture
it just blocks everything out of her
mind
i'm like i'm happy i was in junior high
and my mom knocked on my bedroom door
and i was like oh [ __ ]
something must happen because she never
knocks right and then i was like
she just barges in yeah she just walks
in and then saw i hear the knife or
after you've
she caught you [ __ ] a pillow or
sandwich wait change things
this is before i [ __ ] up okay okay okay
so i open the door and i'm like
what and then she's like yeah uh what's
calm
how cute what
she asked that like well she asked me in
japanese but then
when she said come she said it in
english and i'm like
what do you mean like come and i was
like oh yeah and i said in japanese
that's just semen and she goes oh and
then she turned around and walked away
and i'm thinking maybe because i was
coming all over
like the massage things she probably
someone told her that's come
and then she's all like what is it no
you didn't even clean after yourself
what massage they were most they were we
had a bunch of massage equipment right
like from like different
vibrating machines to like neck pillow
kind of things that massaged
and i loved [ __ ] all of that [ __ ]
and i would just bust on it and leave it
there so are you dry
pumping animals the machines are your
it's like skin on machine contact
skin on machine like oh my god
[Laughter]
i didn't know at the time but then it
took me years to like realize what was
happening or like why she asked that
question
or i still don't know i got to ask her
did you want to get caught kind of you
were like no
i call her up and i'll ask her why did
she ask me what [ __ ] was so [ __ ] just
comes out and then you're like
oops and you just ah yeah my grandma had
this one
neck pillow thing it was covered it was
your grandma's thing
who's like it was like a neck pillow
thing and it was
really dope like it was nice and
vibrating right and then i was like
using it one day and i'm like man why do
old people love massaging
and then i would like rub it on my body
and then i went to my dick and i wrapped
it around my dick and i'm like
oh my [ __ ] god this is why old people
like it
what if your grandma saw it she like
winked at you would you be like what the
[ __ ] that's the best thing is this guy
opening a christmas present and it's a
massager and he's like
thank you we should all get a membership
didn't you feel weird seeing them use it
after you [ __ ] it
i don't know i don't remember i was like
12. that's old enough
really it is yeah that's how i feel
seeing people hug nikki after i [ __ ]
her
up i don't know if i'd do that
when was the last time that happened
because you guys haven't been out dude
yeah because that
i thought i had a kidney stone again oh
no way
yeah i've i've had this like pain in my
sight turns out he's just a little [ __ ]
no kidding me i was like for like for
like 13 days or something now
what was it we don't know yet little
[ __ ]
it's gone right now as of as of this
morning it's gone for the first time
and a urine test there's nothing there
nothing what if it's a phantom kidney
stone that's what i was thinking like a
placebo kidney stone
so normally me would not go get checked
out because i'm not in that much pain
like where it's crazy but
but well it lasted so long that i was
like this is not normal
it lasted over a week and he still
hadn't seen a doctor and he kept talking
describing
kidney stones and like in the daytime
he'd be like oh it's fine i'm not in
pain
but at night he'd be like this is
definitely kidney stone or maybe i have
liver cancer or like something crazy
dude you spin out you spit out you're
going we're in america though
compared to before well true that way i
can pay out the ass if i
[Laughter]
it's the best system it was so annoying
because he wouldn't
he wouldn't like want to go to a doctor
till it was like 12 at night and i'm
like the only thing open is the
emergency room so
it's better to be a [ __ ] emergency or
else it's 500 bucks
is it 500 worth of pain right now
exactly did you sleep it off or what
happened
well today no like it's i mean they
basically just gave me good ibuprofen
oh yeah the milgram tablets that's not
great so you paid 500 bucks
no we i made him wait till the urgent
care in the morning
unless this is a goddamn emergency you
didn't have to make me wait i love the
deals
yeah i was high five this [ __ ] hold
into the paper
500 i mean deal with the pain it's 500
now or hold and it's 60 bucks it wasn't
even the pain it was that i was spitting
out mentally about it
because you're going for the peace of
mind you go on webmd you go on no
don't ever go on with it that's what i
was saying my website should be banned
yeah
good everything's canceled and the
doctors [ __ ] hate it too
yeah doctors are like why no don't no
let me talk to you right you always you
always self-diagnosed wrong
so like when i had my whole eczema stuff
when i was doing my entire research i'm
like ah this is what it is so i go
into the dermatologist going so this is
what i looked up
i know it's this this this this all i
need from you to prescribe me this and
it goes
that's not even what you have you really
came in
i already got it figured out i gotta
figure it out you're welcome i'm like i
cross reference like five different
sites i know exactly what it is
it's either this or it's this and then i
thought it was i was
allergic to fenugreek or it was uh i was
like allergic to creatine or something
he goes no it's none of those
it's your swimming pool and i'm like oh
so funny if it really was one of those
but he was like well [ __ ] i'm the doctor
i need to know more than you no it's not
it's not he's just making it up that's
cause you guys looking at the wrong
content
you gotta look for some type of mystical
looking person
right they got a shaman do they have to
yeah preferably like a hippie guy or
whatever
he's got some stones he's got like a
little gong then he goes like this and
he's meditating you're basically
describing me but like an old man
so far but i'll just go to nicki's house
but they tell you
that the secret to health is ginger you
know
i got [ __ ] ginger and then you put
that in your tea and you go
kidney stones bye-bye oh you should have
just called your mom then
yeah my mom knows all kinds of people
like that you know what's crazy for me
though is like any time i've actually
like gone spinning and like gone through
all that and then
just like decided on one it takes like a
couple days but then i go to the doctor
it actually got confirmed
like i when i had like a parasite in my
foot i was like
it's a hook worm i like eliminated all
the other parasites it could possibly be
and like
she's a paradox way back and like my
dermatologist was like i haven't seen
this before and she had to go look at
her book
and she'd take my picture like took a
picture of my foot and then she went to
her book and she's like yeah
it is a hookworm like those are really
rare here in the u.s
and nikki's like not when it's mercury
retrograde well it was actually
did you get it from vietnam no i got it
in tulum
during mercury retrograde let's see when
we went yeah
didn't y'all also get zika too no okay
i wish bro you do i'm done i don't
but then i could have given joe a story
do you guys get that thing where uh
when you go to the doctor it
automatically feels better
yes like where i'm like oh [ __ ] i'm in
so much pain right and you go to the
doctor
you're awesome where your pain is and
it's like it was here
it's like your pain go it hides like it
hides like it's like that with my tooth
too like it's just like that everywhere
and i'm like
i wouldn't be in here but i didn't feel
the pain trust me i feel the pain i
don't know why the [ __ ]
it doesn't hurt right now but it's
somewhere in here or in here or
somewhere here
it's like your dog you've been training
when people are over you want to show
them like hey
look at the tricks and it doesn't
[ __ ] listen to you and then you go
back home and it starts doing the tricks
again
i don't know why it's like that i also
just don't want to complain too much
and even though i'm at the doctor for
pain yeah yeah yeah i want to be
complaining give him a pep talk i'm like
you tell her exactly when
what's you tell her what you told me
and then and then i and then it cuts to
me sitting there and she's like what's
wrong i'm like nothing
yeah i know it's so weird because
doctors you know how they'll check to
see if something hurts
like does that hurt and at that moment
it does but my pride will go nah it
doesn't hurt
do it harder i don't know why and then
later i'll be like yeah it actually kind
of hurt
yo you know how you can alleviate pain
it kind of like helps your body a little
bit
how our sponsor feels
that's true cbd that helps lately i've
been feeling kind of like
stressed for for just no odd reason i
think i'm overworking myself and my mind
right
and what i usually do is like all i'll
go and like
i like run outside or whatever but
thankfully
i'm sponsored by feels in this video we
got
feels thank you very much oh yeah and
uh they sent me a little package it's
cbd
products and it's pretty damn amazing
because there's this oil in there i just
put it on my tongue i just be like
and then um in a couple of minutes it
starts relaxing me i start feeling like
the feels you know i don't know if you
guys ever tried cbd oil or whatever
yeah yeah it's not like smoking weed
where you feel like
completely high you can't even move or
anything like that right you just
for me i put it in like a herbal tea i
go sipping away
and i feels fancy i do the pinky thing
right here and i'm like
it's delicious yeah it just cuts that
anxiety out like
no no high just yeah it takes the edge
off yeah your entire body just feels
like more relaxed
and i can ease into whatever transition
i want to do like whether it's going to
sleep or
like get my mind off of the day and then
kind of
yeah it's it's been kind of cool so if
you guys
feel like you have a little bit of edge
you need to take off feels has me
feeling my best every day and you can
too
become a member today by going to
feels.com off the record
and you'll get 50 off your first order
with free shipping that's a lot
that's f e a l um f-e-a-l-s
dot com slash off the record become a
member and get 50
automatically taking off your first
order with free shipping
fields.com off the record and it comes
in a real cool box
yeah because i've used cbd before and it
definitely feels more relaxing
also uh when i sprained my ankle at
tycho's birthday oh yeah
yeah david yeah he brought like the
roller thing and that completely helped
my ankle because it was i felt like i
broke it it was so
swollen and oh my god it was horrible
that made me a believer i had never
tried cbd before then
oh because you had tried it too no no i
mean like
after that yeah okay yeah after i saw
because i had a couple
different things but i just never tried
it i was too scared and then i saw that
happen with you and i was like
it's a miracle thing oh cool yeah do you
guys ever have
phantom pain yeah yeah all the time
it's like there's no yeah that's what
steve has it's
like it's kind of like there's no you go
to the doctor
you get x-rays you get all this stuff
and then nothing's there and they're
like you're fine
but then you feel the pain though where
i got my stent
when i they removed my kidney stone the
first time when they blasted out of me
yeah uh
i can feel that if i don't go to the
bathroom for a certain amount of time i
feel a dull ache where they had the
stent in my body like it comes back and
it haunts you
yeah it's almost like a physical ptsd
oh that makes sense your body remembers
it and it just like is it phantom pain
when you have a boner
and then you're like you need someone to
help you get rid of it but they don't
help you
and then it just it just keeps staying
there and it's like throbbing it's there
it's not phantom
uh very smart no but the phantom part is
the part that used to belong around it
there used to be something
covering it you know that's something
that's the painful part that you're
saying
maybe it's missing phantom pleasure
that's a [ __ ] flesh
phantom oh dude the pussy's happening to
me dude that's a [ __ ] when you have
this [ __ ] on your back
right now okay bro what happened to his
back what is it wait what what
what are we showing happening this is
lumbar every month bart has a new thing
to share with you this chair has these
chairs have long bars
not enough wait we can't see it this is
lumbar support pick up your chair
what's going on dude hey we should give
them a back brace like
that helped me a lot when i was working
in the warehouse this guy needs a bubble
let me give you a little tip bart when
you lift you got to use one of those
weight belts
okay yeah yeah yeah that's what i use i
just pulled my back uh
deadlifting the other day and um i
one of my buddies who's like a
chiropractor he's also like a lifter so
he kind of understands like
the mechanics of how it transfers into
injuries and he was like your
your back has been spazzing out because
i just haven't been you know like you
you want to have balance right so if i
just been dead
this whole time and i'm not working out
abs as much then eventually you kind of
have like this duck butt action
that's what i have you might have duck
butt too so so i have this duck butt
action so when i was deadlifting um and
i'm my spine's not neutral
so it's just like one not good movement
it pulled it out of position and then so
i have this back spasm so it just locks
up and my
butt gets locked in this duct position
dude every month you've been in like
something
in 2020 it's been [ __ ] up and that's
crazy
mercury i know right it's crazy man wait
what's mercury retrograde everyone keeps
talking about it i keep forgetting isn't
it like something
do you want this conversation yes i need
it all right put your ears [ __ ] put
your hair behind your ears girl get
ready buckle up because i know about the
transition
in erica the mercury [ __ ]
retrograde
okay she likes to come in here and [ __ ]
you is she why is it she
because it usually is i mean she's just
temperamental on camera
mars is a heat for sure yeah but then
like they're destructive in different
ways
yeah because they control different
areas so mercury controls
uh communication travel electronics
she [ __ ] it up look we can't there's a
travel ban everywhere everywhere
yeah she [ __ ] it up and there's three
a year okay and so jupiter has also been
in retrograde
and jupiter controls like beauty
and some other [ __ ] i don't really
remember so it makes everybody ugly it
was venus
i don't remember listen the other ones
aren't that important because they don't
go retrograde that much and since
they're farther away they don't affect
you as much but like if you want to know
about them
what's jupiter is that like you're so
close yes
no because so mercury is female right
jupiter makes you stupider
and mars is mars is a dude well
mars is based off of the god of aries
the god of war
yup my favorite that's me aries mars got
bars you with the [ __ ] happy bill
shirt
i'm the god of war your branding's off
i like to go running in a field
so yeah anything to do with
communication and stuff
but it is really good to like review
things any start anything that starts
with re
like review repair uh redo
redecorate like any of that stuff is
fine cover
yeah so how come mercury gets all the
fame because mercury is closer to us so
it affects more
and like it just [ __ ] everything up and
everybody like kind of feels it at the
same time
um whereas like the other planets are
farther away so they don't really do as
much
is there a mars retrograde yeah there is
there's a bunch of planets that have
been in retrograde lately at the same
time but
yeah what does it mean to be in
retrograde okay it looks like the
planets are moving backwards but they're
not it's just the way that they're
orbiting around the sun
it's like the way that we're orbiting
next to them it makes it look like
they're going backwards
to us but they're not really it's just
the is it is it like when you're in a
car
and the other car is running backwards
and it looks like you're like going
forward or whatever get the honk
oh and so yeah
and mercury's um retrograde only lasts
for three weeks
only right it feels like forever tell me
about it girl
this this particular last one there were
like three planets in retrograde but the
other ones last for like a couple months
at a time
you just don't feel them as hard are you
guys ready for a quick
um this would get set on the view and
get a thunderous applause
i think the earth is in retrograde right
now
what happens when the earth is in
retrograde it doesn't because though
basically it's based off of everything
around us so like
we're the center like oh these planets
are moving backwards to us
but if we live on mars then we can't
experience right there yeah there is an
earth retrograde but what about the moon
though that's the closest one to us
is there a moon retrograde i don't think
so because it orbits around us
oh so then they can't affect it because
if it's like
this one but it affects our tides and
[ __ ] it does
that's true the strongest one women's
emotions
too it does yeah cause like the tide and
it doesn't affect their [ __ ] eyes i
know
tell me about it girl [ __ ] full moons
apparently affect everyone's emotions
because
because i heard all kinds of [ __ ] up
full moon stories like what
phantom penis pains no well yeah that's
one of them but no but people doing
crazy [ __ ] during full moons it's been
like werewolf
it's been told it's been talked about
for hundreds of years yeah like e.t
no he goes home yeah he then goes across
the moon
but no you haven't heard that like the
full moon like people get crazy during a
full moon
took a whole thing really oh no i just
go oh full moon and i go back inside
that's true true i like it when the moon
is really big
and you're like driving on the freeway
at night and you're just like it looks
like mart yeah
it only lasts like that for a few
minutes and then it goes back to being
tiny
yeah it's so weird like by the time you
tell anyone it goes back to tiny
like are you crazy then you took a
picture of it to show everyone and then
it's just like a regular moon on your
phone you're like no i swear to god it
was [ __ ] huge
what the hell no one else heard this
thing because i had never heard of it
until i heard it that one time
but if you take photos of the moon when
you're pregnant it's like bad luck
why what's it gonna do to your baby i
don't know like supposedly it's like
really bad luck
if you're gonna look at it because i i
was taking photos of the moon because it
looked really pretty
i wonder you got so much bad luck see
yeah that's why don't do it guys
no but yeah i was just so like what like
i've never heard of this is this like
one
another one of those like wives tales
things people could make
anything up that's true and we could
make something up right now and people
start believing a lot of shit's based on
stories and stuff like from our
from the ancient times and like ancient
cultures and stuff
yeah before we had tv or anything
because they were bored
well now you're trying to find meaning
from life it's not that i found one time
i found a dino chicken another that kind
of looked like jesus
yeah right no i really did and i took a
picture of it but it didn't happen it
doesn't look like it on the picture
but but it looked like jesus in real
life yeah what does this
look like how do you know oh yeah it's
true i know he was golden and breaded
[Music]
do
you